hey this is presh talwalkar
when the day after tomorrow is yesterday
then today will be as far from wednesday
as today was from wednesday when the day
before yesterday was tomorrow
what day is today
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
one difficulty in the problem is the
word today refers to three different
days
the first reference of today i'll mark
as the green day
the next reference i'll denote as orange
day
and the day we want to solve for today
i'll say is the blue day
so when is the green day
this is when the day after tomorrow
would be referred to as yesterday
so relative today as day x
tomorrow will be x plus 1
the day after tomorrow is x plus 2
and we would refer to the day after
tomorrow as yesterday if we go one more
day forward to x plus three
now let's solve for the orange day
relative to today this will be when the
day before yesterday would be referred
to as tomorrow
if today is day x
then yesterday is x minus one
the day before yesterday is x minus two
and that day would be referred to as
tomorrow if we go one more day back to x
minus three
so the green day is three days ahead of
today
and the orange day is three days before
today
we need the green and orange days to be
an equal distance from wednesday
when does this happen
it exactly happens when x is equal to
wednesday because that means green will
be three days after wednesday and orange
will be three days before wednesday
therefore
today is wednesday
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description